if you deploy your application to
appspot you can explore the entities in
the data store using the admin console
let's take a quick demo of how to get
there so to get to the admin console you
go to console developers.google.com/jobs
there's this one project here and then
you click on that you click on the
project that you want to investigate and
it will take you to the dashboard for
your project so you see there's a App
Engine section that lets you get to
various things about App Engine I think
you already looked at that so if you
click down here you see the cloud
datastore option and this will take you
to the dashboard for your datastore
dashboard shows you various kinds of
information about your project you can
get statistics of all your entities you
get breakdown by property type you can
get the total size of the entities that
are stored in the datastore see this
here the indexes you'll be learning
about indexes really soon so go ahead
you can go ahead and explore the
dashboard see what kinds of information
is in there what I really want to talk
about is the query so if you click query
it takes you to the page where you can
find out information about the entities
that have been saved this kind menu just
like in the local host admin console
lists the kinds of entities that are
stored right now I only have profile
these other two things are internal to
App Engine I'm looking at the entities
of kind profile I've only got one that's
the profile that I just created you can
see the display name the main email the
t-shirt size you can drill down into it
if you want you can even change the
values here obviously you really only
want to do that during development this
is where you would come to check your
entities and it can be a really useful
tool